son sens du placement et sa qualité de
passe ont ravi les spectateurs du parc
des princes entre 2006 et 2015 l'ancien
parisien clément chantôme ou foule
aujourd'hui les terrains de national 2
le joueur rejoint l'as poissy en 2020
après avoir arrêté sa carrière pendant
six mois c'est la passion qui est qui
reprend le dessus et puis moi j'étais
habitué depuis que j'ai l'âge de 12 ans
d'être enceinte m'entraîne tous les
jours et le fait d'arrêter pendant six
mois juste assez jeunes beaucoup d'envié
revenu depuis clément chantôme joue
régulièrement avec l'équipe une de
poissy le sportif veut transmettre son
expérience acquise lors de ses 300
matches passés sur les pelouses de ligue
1 avec le psg toulouse bordeaux et
rennes c'est bon joueur le plus régulier
déjà qui restait des puits depuis la
préparation il reste à un niveau très
intéressant et il répète ces matches là
donc c'est la différence qu'il ya entre
lui et les autres joueurs après
forcément c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'avoir un clément chantôme avec avec
soi que rencontre aujourd'hui le
footballeur vtd poissy à se maintenir en
nationale 2 le club est pour l'instant
11e sur 16 on aurait pu mieux faire
parce que on a une équipe qui joue très
bien cette année ont je pense que les
résultats vous fait même pas le
classement même si c est fait mieux
cette année on aurait peut-être encore
plus haut à 34 ans la motivation semble
toujours présente au plus grand bonheur
des spectateurs de national plus